[Music]
the long-awaited JFK files are out in
part 2800 never-before-seen records on
the assassination of JFK were released
by the National Archives but hundreds
remain classified President Trump said
he had no choice but to heed warnings
from the CIA and FBI to keep some of the
files secret for further review
releasing them unredacted could pose
irreversible harm to our national
security
here's some of what we learned from
documents that were allowed to go public
in the aftermath of the assassination
the Soviets apparently worried they
would be blamed for putting Lee Harvey
Oswald up to the attack more on that
later also the CIA once intercepted a
phone call from Lee Harvey Oswald to the
KGB's department in charge of sabotage
and assassination before Oswald murdered
the president another interesting item a
British newspaper received an anonymous
phone call about quote big news in the
u.s. 25 minutes before JFK was shot so
there actually was some big news in here
Kimberly you know it's interesting
because this is I found to be one of the
more fascinating topics did you ever
think in our you know lifetime that they
would reopen these files and it's the
question that I'm getting from everyone
is you know what are we gonna find out
or something's gonna be held back and I
said well I think we're gonna find out
what they feel comfortable with us you
know knowing in terms of what transpired
here I think it's an important moment in
American political history and just in
transparency for our government also
because we're a lot of times we'll say
to other governments what you guys are
doing you're not being transparent
you're not being open I think this shows
that actually we trust the American
people to know this information even
though this dealt with one of our top
secret intelligence
you know agencies and to me that's like
kind of the most compelling aspect I
don't know that I necessarily found
something in this that was
earth-shattering or altered kind of my
fact pattern or the chronology as a
prosecutor of what I thought went down
but in that very sense I think it's
helpful because people were thinking
there was a big conspiracy behind this
and wondering what was going on or if
our government was keeping secrets from
us you can't get away from the Russians
Greg Keep Calm
in this show you know what I love about
the Russians they have a department in
charge of sabotage an assassination they
play the villain to a tee they'll put
the sign up there yeah and say yeah just
go to the Department of assassination
and sabotage we have the cloaks over
there and the daggers are in the locker
by the way speaking of assassins these
some of the best stuff here are the
plots to kill Castro this is the United
States now contaminated skin diving suit
dusted the dusted with a deadly fungus
inside they were also got a booby trap
what they called a spectacular sea shell
so cuz Castro Castro enjoyed diving and
they were gonna put a shell that had
bombs in it but they couldn't find a
large enough self shining on I want this
job to sit around and come up with
fantastic ideas it's incredible the only
thing is that the problem with this and
I can see why some people are
disappointed it's like when you go to
the carnival or a County Fair and
there's a sideshow and they feel like
this is a bearded lady and you're really
excited as a ten-year-old and if the guy
in a dress and it pulls on ya and or
they say so they would say like it's a
monster rabbit but it's like a goat with
rabbit ears it is actually I felt like
we got led on a little bit but my last
point hmm Rachel Maddow just hammered
Trump over this last night saying how
they couldn't get it right
she's been carnival barking for nine
months over Russian collusion with Trump
and there's more meat on a cricket in
that story so it's like she's
essentially going after president Trump
for what she's been doing every night
from 9-10 clarifying a sixty-year-old
conspiracy basically that's exactly what
happens every night it's you've done a
lot of research on this today and I
wonder what your biggest well we have a
team of Watters world researchers going
over this page by page so I really do
the final decision we've come to it is
funny off of Rachel Maddow how you know
the left fantasizes about assassinating
President Trump and then when he doesn't
release things that might actually help
other countries assassinate him through
the CIA documents now she's mad so I
don't I don't
she did she never said the left mad
because Trump like withheld some of the
stuff because the CI doesn't want any of
their I want to put like repellant up no
we're going to be releasing those
documents later on the waters world show
by the CIA Richard to hold some of these
documents back but he has in six months
it will be revisited again so we will be
able to hold all of this information and
bring it back up
I actually am I actually I don't
understand The Secret Service knew that
he was going to do this and they should
have gotten their act together to
release all the documents at one time
meaning President Trump or Lee Harvey
[Music]
Oswald's the whole table now but no I'm
saying that the secret said the
intelligence agencies knew the president
wanted release his documents
he sent the memo over they're required
by the line in 1992 Socktober 26 that we
17 this will all be released right
there's a security concern which there
was and president Truong he did right
and I just I feel as though that the
Secret Service had almost a decade to
get their act together to figure out the
security concerns and deal with it and I
applaud the president for releasing
these documents because I think the
American people deserve to know what
happened to JFK and I think the now we
could put all of these conspiracy
theories to bed the third bullet the
umbrella man the the elbe that LBJ did
it
all of these conspiracies can now go to
bed and we can move on and say he was
assassinated we now all know we didn't
know was Lee Harvey Oswald didn't now we
know well on the two o'clock show today
the daily briefing so Jim Woolsey the
former CIA director was there yeah and
basically what he said is that there is
a theory about this guy who was a
Romanian agent and he became he descent
defected to the United States highest
level guy and he said that Khrushchev
had wanted Jay
kay assassinated so there was a plan
going forward but then he called it off
but Lee Harvey Oswald was such a
die-hard believer that he went forward
with it and then they had Jack Ruby kill
him to make sure that there was no
couldn't find that connection you buy
that Kimberly I had to tell you
something for me some of these series I
had already heard before you know that
they weren't very like revealing to me
and the Jack Ruby stuff I thought was
kind of interesting the other thing
about going to get a confession in the
hospital I thought that was kind of
interesting but then really not able to
do that was like sort of a last minute
press to try to get that nugget to say
okay we can wrap this up and close it
down and what the history would have
been very different I think if they had
been able to obtain that and then just
the one other thing Dana that I found
was really interesting was the phone
call
there was an intercept of a phone call
connecting like we talked about the
Russians I mean they're everywhere
between Oswald and then also a death
threat against him those things were
pretty interesting that I thought were
like new and kind of again revealing I
thought that was he was making a lot of
sense Greg what do you think about this
British newspaper getting a warning 25
minutes before the news broke I
sometimes I just think that is they
might think you do you get a lot of
chatter yeah I think all the time and
you get that with terrorist attacks as
well so it may have just been a
coincidence I don't know who warned them
I don't know that part but it is it's
it's interesting when you eat what
you're getting is a look at what happens
all the time
things that you don't know that's going
what's going on when I go back to the
Castro stuff we were doing this to like
we were planning to off you know the
head of a country because you know he's
a you know because we didn't like him
and I and I look at this stuff and I go
this is really amazing and we must be
doing this now or maybe we don't but I
wonder how many people have no idea that
no idea what we're talking about because
you know it's 50 some-odd how what is it
16 how many years where are we now 53
years ago 54 yeah so many humans spent
so much time in fictitious worlds you
know playing video games that they the
history is not as interesting it does
also show you how the intelligence
community Bay
Scalia's looking through thousands of
haystacks right the chances of finding
the needle are pretty slim well I mean
thread here and I the bomb if he's going
to the embassy tell us at the Mexico the
Russian embassy knees meeting with these
assassination squads and he's making
calls and he's speaking Russian were
broken Russian they got him on a wiretap
how is it not a conspiracy and then you
look at Hoover the FBI director making
sure the public doesn't think it's a
conspiracy you can see what's what make
sure that there's not World War three
because if everybody starts thinking the
Russians were involved in a plot to
assassinate the president United States
they're gonna want to go to war and that
might be why the national security
community is still concerned about the
release of all these documents so true
the other thing that's what is that the
Warren Commission who wish LBJ put put
on because people thought that he had
done it and they didn't even have any of
these documents at that when they were
when they started their investigation so
it says that there was tension between
the FBI and the CIA so some things never
change yeah